- Riding a blind horse,
that's a little different.
But to me it don't make much difference.
He's a pretty good friend.
He’s just tickled to death to be rode.
I think he knows that he got eyes then,
and he just jumps up and down
and runs and really likes to go.
My name's Roderick Olsen,
in Soldier Grove, Wisconsin.
I have always had a few
horses, matter of fact,
quite a few of them.
Well, we got Zaxson about 21 years ago,
about 10 years ago that we
noticed that he was going blind.
Far as we could find out,
nothing we could do about it.
Most of the old horse dealers,
or farmers, they'd just
get rid of the horse.
But I figured I'd then keep him.
I'd like to stick around a while longer,
so if I went blind, I hope
they'd keep me around a while.
I didn't figure he was useless.
He does everything you want
by the feel of the reins.
He's a little different
riding than a regular horse.
He's careful when he's running,
you know he ain't sure
where his feet's going to go
or what's in front of him.
But he didn't just quit
because he got blind,
he's trying to do things so
he can take care of himself.
He trusts me to ride him.
I think he just figures
that man I can see now.
I got eyes.
I can do things that I
wanted to do for a long time.
He wants to just run.
He's fun for me to ride.
We go all over the
hills, down the canyons,
in the water, everywhere
that any other horse can go.
He does just fine.
He must trust me and, well, I trust him.
He's kind of a buddy anyhow.
Being friends with a horse, that’s a, I don't know
that's the way it's been
with me all my life.